es la primera vez que eeuu atribuye la
culpa cuando se trata de los
enfrentamientos fronterizos entre
armenia y azerbaiyán la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes de eeuu nancy
pelosi visitó la capital de armenia y
dijo que estaba claro que el reciente
estallido había sido provocado por los
ataques a series también dijo que
washington quería apoyar a ereván en sus
necesidades de defensa
y la seguridad territorial y la
soberanía de armenia la democracia de
armenia es un valor para nosotros en
eeuu
deberíamos utilizar nuestra influencia
nuestro apalancamiento mostrando que la
democracia y la soberanía armenias son
una prioridad
azerbayán no tardó en responder acusando
a pelosi de poner en peligro la paz en
la región las acusaciones infundadas e
injustas lanzadas por pelosi contra
azerbaiyán son inaceptables armenia y
azerbayán se culpan mutuamente en el
inicio de los recientes bombardeos el
mayor brote de hostilidades en más de
dos años el miércoles por la noche entró
en vigor un alto
el presidente de la cámara armenia
agradeció de eeuu sus mediaciones
después de que fracasaran los intentos
anteriores de rusia de negociar una
tregua rusia es un estrecho aliado
militar de armenia mientras que
azerbaiyán cuenta con el apoyo de
turquía los dos países exsoviéticos
llevan décadas en conflicto por el
territorio de nagorno karabaj parte de
azerbayán que estuvo durante mucho
tiempo bajo el control de las fuerzas
étnicas armenias respaldadas por elevan
durante una mortífera guerra de seis
semanas en 2020 azerbayán recuperó
amplias zonas del territorio